I was in the kitchen cooking some food for my dog, which I don't say with pride. I don't even approve of people cooking for their dogs, but he's got health problems and without boring you with a lot of details, there's no getting around it. And I was listening to Marketplace, which is actually the point of this story I'm telling you. I was listening to the radio on Marketplace and I heard this commentary by one of the regular commentators, this conservative commentator, David Frum, who said that new numbers had just been released by the government. Showing that when you look at family incomes-- and what happened to family incomes during the Bush presidency.
我当时在厨房里给我的狗做饭，这话我说得一点也不自豪。我甚至不赞成人们自己给狗做饭，但他有健康问题，我不想在这儿啰唆细节，总之是没办法绕过这一点。我当时在听《市场》(Marketplace)节目，这其实才是我要讲的重点。我听着广播里的《市场》节目，听到了常驻评论员之一，那位保守派评论员大卫·弗鲁姆(David Frum)的一段评论，他说政府刚刚发布了新的数据。数据显示，当你审视家庭收入——以及布什总统任期内家庭收入发生了什么变化时。
George W. Bush has the worst economic performance of any two-term president since the numbers were collected. Jimmy Carter did worse, but he only had one term.
乔治·W·布什在任期两届的总统中，其经济表现是自统计数据以来最差的。吉米·卡特做得更差，但他只任职了一届。
I asked Frum to come onto our show to talk about this finding.
我邀请弗鲁姆来到我们的节目，讨论这一发现。
This is a little painful. I was part of the Bush administration. In fact, I was part of the Bush administration's economic team. So I take this a little personally.
这有点令人痛苦。我曾是布什政府的一员。事实上，我曾是布什政府经济团队的一员。所以我对此感到有点个人化。
But Frum says, and this was his point on Marketplace , that it's important to understand why Bush's performance was so bad. Frum says that over those eight years what employers actually paid for each worker rose. And it rose a lot: 25%. But--
但弗鲁姆说——这也是他在《市场》节目中的观点——了解为什么布什的表现如此糟糕很重要。弗鲁姆说，在那八年里，雇主为每个工人实际支付的费用实际上是上升的。而且涨幅很大，达到25%。但是——
Employees received none of that money. The median American worker was earning less in the year 2007 than that worker was earning adjusting for inflation in the 2000. And yet, his employer was paying 25% more. So where did that money go? And the answer is, it all went to pay the rising cost of health care.
员工并没有得到那笔钱中的任何一部分。美国工人的收入中位数在2007年时的收入，经通胀调整后，反而比2000年时还要低。然而，他的雇主却多支付了25%。那么钱去哪儿了呢？答案是，这些钱全部用来支付不断上涨的医疗保健费用了。
The average cost of a health insurance policy for a family of four between 2000 and 2007 more than doubled, from $6,000 to $13,000. A $7,000 climb. Coincidentally, during the boom years of President Clinton, when Americans did so well, family incomes rose about that same amount, $6,500. This is just how quickly health care costs are rising in this country.
2000年至2007年间，四口之家的平均医疗保险费用翻了一倍多，从6000美元涨到了13000美元。涨了7000美元。巧合的是，在克林顿总统的繁荣时期，也就是美国人表现得非常好的时候，家庭收入的增长幅度也差不多是这么多，大约6500美元。这就是这个国家医疗保健费用上涨的速度。
If you take into account health care, George W. Bush stops being the worst two-term president in the modern America era for family incomes.
如果你把医疗保健考虑在内，乔治·W·布什就不再是现代美国史上家庭收入表现最差的两届总统了。
If you were to compare, say, President Bush's performance to Harry Truman's or the Ford-Carter years, it looks good. If you compare it to the Clinton years, the Reagan years, or the Johnson years, it doesn't look so good.
如果你把布什总统的表现与哈里·杜鲁门或福特-卡特时期相比，看起来还不错。如果你拿它和克林顿时期、里根时期或约翰逊时期相比，那就没那么好看了。
So basically he's somewhere in the middle? He's kind of like--
所以基本上他处于中间水平？他就像是——
No, I would say the lower part of the middle. I don't want to oversell the record.
不，我会说是在中间偏下的水平。我不想过度吹捧这份记录。
Rising health care costs are affecting everything in the economy. Rising health care costs are the thing that's driving our health care system off the rails. It's what's led so many people to being uninsured. It's making it hard for US businesses to compete. It's gobbling up more and more of all spending in the United States.
日益上涨的医疗保健费用正在影响经济的方方面面。不断上涨的医疗成本正是导致我们医疗体系脱轨的原因。正是这一点导致了那么多人没有保险。这也使得美国企业难以竞争。它正在吞噬美国越来越多的支出。
I saw this number recently that said that at the current rate of growth, in just 9 years, the amount that the average American family is going to spend on health care each year is going to be $38,000. $38,000. That's more than half of what family income will be that year. What was striking about that was that this isn't one of those projections that the government does looking at health care costs 75 years from now, showing how grim it's going to be far in the future. This is nine years from now at the current rate of growth. Basically, this is going to happen. Half of our incomes are going to be going to health care very, very soon, unless somebody does something.
我最近看到一个数字，说按照目前的增长速度，仅在9年内，美国家庭每年平均在医疗保健上的支出将达到38000美元。38000美元。这超过了该年家庭收入的一半。最令人震惊的是，这并非政府那种展望75年后医疗成本的预测，那种预测只是展示未来将会有多么严峻。这是九年后的情况，按目前的增长速度。基本上，这一定会发生。除非有人采取行动，否则很快，我们收入的一半将要花在医疗保健上。
At this point, we, Americans, spend 50% more on health care than any country in the world, and the money isn't buying us better health. If you look at the numbers, when it comes to infant mortality compared to other countries, we are 45th. Worse than Cuba. When it comes to life expectancy, we're 50th. Behind, by the way, Bosnia and South Korea. And so today we ask the question, why is this happening? What's going on in health care that makes it so impossible to hold costs down?
在这一点上，我们美国人在医疗保健上的花费比世界上任何国家都多50%，而且这些钱并没有为我们买来更好的健康。如果你看看数据，在婴儿死亡率方面与其它国家相比，我们排名第45位。比古巴还差。在预期寿命方面，我们排名第50位。顺便提一下，落后于波斯尼亚和韩国。所以今天我们提出这个问题，为什么会发生这种情况？医疗保健领域究竟发生了什么，使得控制成本变得如此不可能？
We're tackling these questions now, this week, as health care is being debated in Washington. Because fixing our health care system means fixing two different things: getting more people covered by insurance and slowing the increases in health care costs. And the bills on Capitol Hill right now seem much more about solving the insurance problem than about controlling costs.
我们现在，也就是本周，正在解决这些问题，因为华盛顿正在辩论医疗保健问题。因为修复我们的医疗保健体系意味着要解决两件不同的事情：让更多的人获得保险覆盖，以及放缓医疗保健费用的增长。而目前国会山上的法案似乎更侧重于解决保险问题，而不是控制成本。
So we're going to do something we've never done. We're going to two shows about this, this week and next week. This is a co-production we're doing with NPR News . Next week, the most entertaining hour, I guarantee, that you're ever going to hear on the insurance industry. This week, we ask why costs keep rising.
所以我们将做一件我们从未做过的事情。我们本周和下周要对此做两期节目。这是我们与NPR新闻联合制作的。下周，我保证，你将听到关于保险业最精彩的一小时节目。本周，我们来探讨为什么成本持续上涨。
From WBEZ Chicago it's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International, I'm Ira Glass. Our show today in four acts. Act one, Dartmouth Atlas Shrugged, in which we examine whether doctors are the ones to blame for rising costs. Act two, Every Cat Scan has Nine Lives, in which we wonder if patients are the problem. Act three, Who Would Win in a Fight Between a Polar Bear and an Insurance Company? Is the problem the insurance companies? And act four, Now What? In which we learn what the new health care bills do to fix all this, if they do anything. Stay with us.
这里是WBEZ芝加哥的《美国生活》(This American Life)，由公共广播国际(PRI)发行，我是艾拉·格拉斯(Ira Glass)。今天的节目分四幕。第一幕，《达特茅斯地图集耸肩》，我们将在其中审视医生是否是造成成本上涨的罪魁祸首。第二幕，《每次CT扫描都有九条命》，我们想知道患者是否才是问题所在。第三幕，《北极熊和保险公司打架谁会赢？》，问题出在保险公司吗？第四幕，《现在怎么办？》，我们将了解新的医改法案是否采取了措施来修复这一切，如果它们确实有什么作用的话。请继续收听。
Act one: Dartmouth Atlas Shrugged.
第一幕：达特茅斯地图集耸肩。
There are all kinds of reasons that health care costs have risen so quickly over the last few decades. We have higher administrative costs than other countries because our health care system with its insurers and providers is so complicated. We use more expensive high tech gear, our drugs cost more. But there's a whole school of thought that blames a lot of the rising costs on doctors. Prescribing drugs that people don't really need, doing too many procedures. And the reason people think this all goes back to the work of one person, a health researcher named Jack Wennberg. NPR science correspondent, Alix Spiegel, explains what that's all about.
过去几十年来，医疗保健成本之所以上涨得如此迅速，原因多种多样。我们的行政成本比其它国家高，因为我们的医疗体系有着保险公司和医疗提供者，结构非常复杂。我们使用更昂贵的高科技设备，我们的药品成本也更高。但有一个流派认为，很多成本上涨应该归咎于医生。比如开一些人们并不真正需要的药物，做太多的手术。人们之所以这么认为，全都要追溯到一个人的工作，他是一位名叫杰克·温伯格(Jack Wennberg)的健康研究员。NPR科学记者艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔(Alix Spiegel)解释了其中的原因。
To understand the work of Jack Wennberg, let's start with one patient and one medical problem, a young woman with a sharp pain in her lower uterus.
要理解杰克·温伯格的工作，让我们从一位病人和一个医学问题开始，一位下子宫有剧痛的年轻女性。
I was having a lot of problem, just a constant ache right here that never went away. And my boss kept saying, you should go get that checked. You should go get that checked. Because I was like doubling right over. It was like a really, really deep ache all the time.
我当时有很多问题，就是这里一直有一种持续的疼痛，从未消失。我的老板一直说，你应该去检查一下。你应该去检查一下。因为我当时几乎都要弯下腰了。那是一种非常、非常深的持续疼痛。
In 1974, Roxanne Tremblay was 29 years old. A single mom living in a small apartment in Lewiston, Maine. Because Roxanne was the only one supporting her young daughter, she had to be able to work, and the pain was getting in the way. The pain was a problem. So Roxanne went to see her gynecologist, a nice man who did a short exam, and then kindly explained that Roxanne would need an operation. Three weeks later, Tremblay had her uterus and ovaries removed, a total hysterectomy.
1974年，罗克珊·特伦布莱(Roxanne Tremblay)29岁。是一位独自住在缅因州刘易斯顿小公寓里的单身母亲。因为罗克珊是抚养幼女的唯一支柱，她必须能够工作，而疼痛阻碍了她。疼痛是个大问题。所以罗克珊去看她的妇科医生，那是个好人，他做了一个简短的检查，然后很友善地解释说罗克珊需要做个手术。三周后，特伦布莱切除了子宫和卵巢，做了一次全子宫切除术。
It was what he called the seed of cancer. It wasn't cancer, but it had the potential of developing into it.
他称之为癌症的种子。那不是癌症，但它有发展成癌症的潜能。
Now Roxanne didn't mind losing her uterus. She never planned to get married or have kids again. But she was slightly surprised that her doctor had been so quick, and before surgery hadn't taken any x-rays or anything.
罗克珊并不介意失去子宫。她从没打算再结婚或生孩子。但她对医生动作如此迅速感到有点惊讶，而且手术前并没有拍X光片之类的东西。
No pictures. No.
没有影像。没有。
He just felt you were--
他只是觉得你是——
And based on what I told him that it should come out.
基于我告诉他的情况，他说应该切除。
29 years old is pretty young for a hysterectomy. But in the mid '70s in Lewiston, Maine, lots of women were getting them. Roxanne, herself, knew a bunch.
29岁做全子宫切除术确实很年轻。但在70年代中期的缅因州刘易斯顿，很多女性都做了这种手术。罗克珊自己就认识一大堆。
My boss that I had when I worked at Kmart, she had one shortly after I did. One of my friends that I've had since I was six years old, she lives right five minutes from here, she had one. Just about anybody you talked to would say, oh, I had a hysterectomy. Oh, yeah. So I did. So and so did mine. Our I just remember there was a lot of them. I do remember that.
我在凯玛特(Kmart)工作时的老板，她在我不久后也做了一个。我从六岁起就认识的一个朋友，她就住在这里五分钟路程的地方，她也做了一个。几乎你交谈过的任何人都会说，哦，我做了子宫切除术。哦，是的。所以我做了。某某人也做了。我只记得当时做的人很多。我确实记得这一点。
Now most Lewiston women, including Roxanne, weren't suspicious about the hysterectomies. And this is where Jack Wennberg's research comes in. Until Jack Wennberg made Lewiston and its hysterectomies famous, no one had even noticed.
大多数刘易斯顿的女性，包括罗克珊，对这些子宫切除术并不怀疑。而这正是杰克·温伯格的研究发挥作用的地方。直到杰克·温伯格让刘易斯顿及其子宫切除术成名之前，没人注意到这一点。
But in the late '70s, Wennberg published a paper, "A Study of Health Care in Maine." And in it he showed that an unusually large number of women in Lewiston were having their uterus removed. He projected that 70% would have a hysterectomy by age 70. While a couple towns over, the number was much smaller-- 25%. That paper was one of a series of studies of Maine and Vermont published by Wennberg in the '70s and '80s. Studies which ultimately, completely transformed our understanding of what's going on in health care in this country. Which is how come I ended up in Wennberg's dining room.
但在70年代末，温伯格发表了一篇论文，《缅因州医疗保健研究》。在其中他展示了刘易斯顿有异常多的女性被切除了子宫。他预测70%的女性在70岁时会接受子宫切除术。而仅仅几个镇之外，这个数字要小得多——25%。那篇论文是温伯格在70和80年代发表的一系列缅因州和佛蒙特州研究之一。这些研究最终彻底改变了我们对这个国家医疗保健现状的理解。这就是我最终出现在温伯格餐厅的原因。
Hello. Hello.
你好。你好。
This is me trying to set the levels on my recording equipment. To do this I asked Wennberg what I ask most people, "could you say a little something?" This is what I got.
这是我试图调整我的录音设备电平。为了做到这一点，我问了温伯格我问大多数人的问题：“你能说点什么吗？”这就是我得到的。
[SPEAKING GERMAN]
（德语演讲）
19th century German poetry. Apparently, for fun in college, Wennberg committed foreign verse to memory. Wennberg's that kind of guy. The kind of guy whose side projects tend to be unusually rigorous. This was certainly the case in health care.
19世纪的德国诗歌。显然，温伯格在大学时为了好玩，把外国诗歌记在了脑子里。温伯格就是那种人。那种副业往往异常严谨的人。在医疗保健领域当然也是如此。
You see, when Wennberg started out in the late '60s, what he was trying to do was improve medicine in the state of Vermont, get better medical services to rural communities. He'd gotten a grant to overhaul Vermont's health care system. But because Wennberg is such a thorough type of fellow, he made a pretty extreme decision. He decided he'd try to collect information about every medical transaction of every person in every town in the whole state. That way he'd know what was going on.
你看，当温伯格在60年代末开始工作时，他试图做的是改善佛蒙特州的医疗水平，为农村社区提供更好的医疗服务。他获得了一笔拨款来改革佛蒙特州的医疗保健体系。但因为温伯格是一个非常彻底的人，他做了一个相当极端的决定。他决定尝试收集该州每个镇每个人的每一笔医疗交易信息。这样他就能知道发生了什么。
What was going on in home health agencies, what was going on in nursing homes, hospitals, doctors' offices. And we need to know for each patient what their diagnosis is, what their treatment was, how much money was spent, and what the outcomes were insofar as we could actually measure them.
居家保健机构发生了什么，疗养院、医院、医生办公室发生了什么。我们需要知道每个病人的诊断是什么，他们的治疗是什么，花费了多少钱，以及在我们能够实际衡量的范围内结果如何。
Now to collect these records, Wennberg hired a bunch of researchers, people dubbed the Pit Crew, who year after year were sent out to medical records rooms to collect records. It was a massive undertaking. Every medical transaction in the state of Vermont. It took two years of road trips just to collect the records for 1969. But once he had all the information, Wennberg began to slice it and dice it in all kinds of ways. And what immediately jumped out was that medicine from town to town in Vermont was practiced in entirely different ways.
为了收集这些记录，温伯格雇佣了一群研究人员，也就是所谓的“维修站人员”(Pit Crew)，他们年复一年地被派往医疗记录室收集记录。这是一项艰巨的任务。佛蒙特州每一笔医疗交易。单是收集1969年的记录就花费了两年的实地考察时间。但一旦他掌握了所有信息，温伯格就开始以各种方式对数据进行剖析。立刻显现出来的是，佛蒙特州城镇之间的医疗实践方式截然不同。
As soon as we set out to do the analyses, we began to see these extraordinary differences.
我们一开始进行分析，就看到了这些非同寻常的差异。
In one town, say 50% of the men would have a prostate procedure. But in another town only 30 miles away, only 15% would. Ditto with mastectomies, hemorrhoid removal, back surgery. Basically, town after town was a version of Lewiston, Maine, in the sense that some procedures might be incredibly numerous, or conversely, incredibly rare.
在一个镇，假设50%的男性会接受前列腺手术。但在仅30英里外的另一个镇，只有15%会接受。乳房切除术、痔疮切除术、背部手术也是如此。基本上，一个又一个城镇都是缅因州刘易斯顿的一个版本，因为有些手术可能非常普遍，或者相反，非常罕见。
It just didn't make sense. We lived right on the boundary between Stowe and Waterbury Center, Vermont. And if my kids had been going to the school system in Stowe, they would have had a 75% chance of getting their tonsils out. If they'd gone to the Waterbury School-- where they actually did-- it was about 20%.
这完全说不通。我们就住在佛蒙特州斯托(Stowe)和沃特伯里中心(Waterbury Center)的边界上。如果我的孩子是在斯托的学区上学，他们切除扁桃体的几率将是75%。如果他们去沃特伯里的学校——他们实际上是在那里上学——几率大约是20%。
So what was going on? Why the differences? Well, there are two possible explanations. The first explanation is that it was the doctors. Doctor behavior was somehow to blame. The second was that it was the patients. That people in some areas were just much sicker than people in other areas. Or maybe they just wanted more services for some reason. Which brings us back to the city of Lewiston, Maine, and yet another woman who had a hysterectomy.
那么发生了什么？为什么会有差异？嗯，有两种可能的解释。第一个解释是医生的问题。医生的行为在某种程度上要负责。第二个解释是病人的问题。某些地区的民众只是比其它地区的民众病得更重。或者可能他们只是出于某种原因想要更多的服务。这又把我们带回了缅因州刘易斯顿市，以及另一位做过子宫切除术的女性。
My little dogs are freaking here.
我的小狗在这里抓狂了。
Oh, hi there, little dogs.
哦，嗨，小狗们。
Come in. You found me.
进来吧。你找到我了。
A couple miles down the way from Roxanne Tremblay, on a quiet Lewiston street, is the home of Carol Bradford. Carol is another Lewiston woman who had her uterus removed in the 1970s. She had fibroids. And like Roxanne, she's happy with the result. But when I asked, Bradford had a theory about the high hysterectomy rate in Lewiston back then. Lewiston, she explained, is mostly Catholic.
在离罗克珊·特伦布莱几英里远的一条安静的刘易斯顿街道上，住着卡罗尔·布拉德福德(Carol Bradford)。卡罗尔是另一位在1970年代切除子宫的刘易斯顿女性。她患有纤维瘤。和罗克珊一样，她对结果很满意。但当我问起时，布拉德福德对当时刘易斯顿的高子宫切除率有一个理论。她解释说，刘易斯顿大部分是天主教徒。
Some women were having too many children. There are families here with 10, 12 children. It's a possibility that women came to the point where they just really couldn't deal with any more children, and were begging the doctors to do something about it. That's my personal opinion.
有些女性生了太多孩子。这里有生10个、12个孩子的家庭。很可能女性到了真的无法再应付更多孩子的地步，于是恳求医生采取措施。这是我的个人观点。
Not just her opinion. Most people assume that when you go into a doctor's office, the doctor is simply responding. Responding to sickness in your body, responding to the needs and concerns you have. But in the studies he did in Vermont and Maine, Wennberg demonstrated that it's a lot more complicated than this. The women of Lewiston weren't having more hysterectomies because more of them were Catholic or because more of them were sick. Wennberg showed that in terms of sickness and demographics, the populations of the communities in states like Maine and Vermont were actually incredibly homogeneous. Which according to Jack Wennberg could mean just one thing: it wasn't the patients.
不仅仅是她的观点。大多数人认为，当你走进医生的办公室时，医生只是在做出反应。对你身体的疾病做出反应，对你有需求和担忧做出反应。但在他在佛蒙特州和缅因州所做的研究中，温伯格证明了事情比这复杂得多。刘易斯顿的女性并没有因为她们更多是天主教徒或更多人患病而接受更多的子宫切除术。温伯格表明，在疾病和人口统计方面，像缅因州和佛蒙特州这样的社区人口实际上是极其同质的。这在杰克·温伯格看来只能意味着一件事：问题不在于病人。
It wasn't true. It wasn't correct. Because we could easily see that it wasn't that patients were different between regions. So it wasn't illness that was driving this. This must be coming from the provider side.
那不是事实。那是不正确的。因为我们可以很容易地看出，地区之间的患者并没有什么不同。所以不是疾病在驱动这一切。这一定是来自医疗提供者一方。
The provider side, the doctors. That was the first insight. That it was doctors not patients that drove medical consumption. And that there are all kinds of things that influenced the decisions a doctor makes when you go into his office. Sickness plays a role, but a much smaller role than we originally thought.
医疗提供者一方，也就是医生。这是第一个洞见。是医生而不是病人推动了医疗消费。并且当你走进医生办公室时，医生所做决定的影响因素有很多。疾病起了一定作用，但作用比我们最初想象的要小得多。
So, what are the things that influence doctor decisions? To answer this question, I went back to Maine to talk to doctors themselves. Doctors who explained that the work of Jack Wennberg inspired a small revolution in the state. You see, after Wennberg published a paper on his early discoveries, a small group of Maine doctors gathered to take action.
那么，影响医生决定的因素是什么呢？为了回答这个问题，我回到缅因州采访医生本人。医生们解释说，杰克·温伯格的工作在该州引发了一场小小的革命。你看，在温伯格发表了一篇关于他早期发现的论文后，一群缅因州医生聚在一起采取行动。
They decided that physicians in Maine should, and could, themselves figure out why these strange geographical variations in care were taking place. And the best way to do that this group figured, was to get all the doctors in Maine to sit down together on a regular basis, look at Maine city by city, and then hash out together why the care they were giving was so different.
他们认为缅因州的医生应该，也能够亲自查明为什么会出现这种奇怪的医疗地域差异。这个小组认为，最好的办法就是让缅因州的所有医生定期坐在一起，逐个查看缅因州的城市，然后共同推敲为什么他们提供的护理会有如此大的差异。
Bob Keller is a back doctor who worked on this project. And he told me that in the beginning there was only one small problem with the plan: many of the doctors in Maine hated it.
鲍勃·凯勒(Bob Keller)是一位致力于该项目的背部医生。他告诉我，起初这个计划有一个小问题：缅因州的许多医生讨厌它。
Number one, they were insulted. They were angry. Their judgment was being challenged. That was not allowed. There were variable responses. In some cases they just didn't believe it, and they would try to find holes in the data. One of the classics. Oh, we have more workers' compensation here. We have more heavy industry here. And we were able to work through most of those things and demonstrate that wasn't the case. But they would-- our population's older. More of them need prostatectomies. Well, we adjust for age, so that's not an argument anymore. And some doctors never could deal with that. And they would leave the study groups. They just said, this is baloney; we're not going along with this.
第一，他们感到被侮辱了。他们很生气。他们的判断力受到了挑战。这是不允许的。反应各不相同。在某些情况下，他们只是不相信，他们试图在数据中找漏洞。其中最经典的一条是：哦，我们这里的工伤赔偿更多。我们这里的重工业更多。我们设法解决了大部分问题，并证明事实并非如此。但他们会说——我们的人口更老。他们中需要前列腺切除术的人更多。好吧，我们已经按年龄进行了调整，所以这不再是理由了。有些医生永远无法接受这一点。他们会离开研究小组。他们只是说，这是废话；我们不打算配合。
But in time, says Keller, many doctors did warm to these ideas.
但凯勒说，随着时间的推移，许多医生确实对这些想法表示欢迎。
They began to accept the data and they began to accept that indeed, different physicians were using different thought processes or decision-making processes in dealing with patients.
他们开始接受数据，并开始承认确实不同的医生在对待病人时使用了不同的思维过程或决策过程。
And so in the state of Maine, for years there was this incredible experiment. Four or five times a year each medical specialty got together for a kind of Talmudic dissection of doctor choice conducted by the doctors themselves. They wanted to look at all of the geographical differences, figure out why they existed, and then try to bring their medical decisions in line with one another. They figured that by doing this they could eliminate unnecessary care.
因此在缅因州，多年来进行了这项不可思议的实验。每种医学专业每年聚会四五次，对医生选择进行一种由医生自己进行的塔木德式的剖析。他们想看看所有的地理差异，弄清楚它们存在的原因，然后尝试使他们的医疗决策相互统一。他们认为通过这样做，他们可以消除不必要的医疗护理。
Now, when talking in these groups, the Maine doctors usually seemed to agree on what criteria they would use for making treatment decisions. So for instance, everyone agreed that you only operate on a back after there'd been three months of pain. But when they went back to the data, it showed that in the privacy of their own offices, many doctors were doing something completely different. Why?
现在，在这些小组讨论时，缅因州的医生通常似乎在制定治疗决策的标准上达成了一致。例如，每个人都同意只有在疼痛持续三个月后才对背部进行手术。但当他们回到数据中时，却显示在自己办公室的私下里，许多医生做的完全不同。为什么？
One possible reason was fear of lawsuits. Some doctors felt that, criteria be damned, if they didn't do every possible thing they might get sued. Another was temperament. Some doctors were just much more eager to take action.
一个可能的原因是担心诉讼。一些医生觉得，哪怕标准见鬼去吧，如果他们不做每一种可能的事，他们可能会被起诉。另一个原因是性格。有些医生只是更渴望采取行动。
Then there was the role of medical culture. In some communities it had evolved over time that, let's say, when a kid got a temperature of 102, he was sent to the hospital. Well, in the next town over, kids with that temperature were advised to just stay home.
还有医疗文化的作用。在一些社区，随着时间的推移，事情演变成，比方说，当一个孩子体温达到102华氏度时，他就会被送往医院。而在隔壁镇，体温达到这个数的孩子会被建议留在家里。
And then there was the number of doctors in a community. One of the many doctors I talked to while I was in Maine was this eye specialist named Frank Read. He's another doc who participated in these groups. And he told me this story.
还有社区里医生的数量。我在缅因州交谈过的众多医生中，有一位叫弗兰克·里德(Frank Read)的眼科专家。他是另一个参加这些小组的医生。他告诉我这样一个故事。
My old partner that I joined here in 1971 was asked by a friend of his, you know, at what level of vision do you do a cataract operation? And he said, well, if there's one ophthalmologist in town, it's 2200.
1971年我和我加入的老合伙人被他的一个朋友问到，你知道，在什么视力水平下你会做白内障手术？他说，嗯，如果镇上只有一个眼科医生，那就是20/200。
2200 is pretty bad vision.
20/200的视力相当差。
If there are two ophthalmologists in town, it's 2080.
如果镇上有两个眼科医生，那就是20/80。
Not so bad vision.
视力没那么差。
If there are three ophthalmologists in town, it's 2040.
如果镇上有三个眼科医生，那就是20/40。
Pretty good vision. In other words, the criteria easily shifts. According to later work done by Jack Wennberg, the number of doctors in an area can influence the amount of medical services consumed.
视力相当不错。换句话说，标准很容易改变。根据杰克·温伯格后来的研究，一个地区医生的数量会影响医疗服务的消费量。
The more doctors, the more appointments, the more procedures, the more money spent. You could actually see this dynamic especially clearly during the '70s. Because to drive down costs in medicine, the federal government created a program to send more people to medical school. The theory was that when there were more doctors, doctors would be forced to drop their prices to compete for patients. Basic economics. But that's not what happened.
医生越多，预约越多，手术越多，花费的钱越多。你实际上可以在70年代特别清楚地看到这种动态。因为为了降低医疗成本，联邦政府创建了一个项目，让更多的人上医学院。理论是，当有更多的医生时，医生将被迫降价以争夺病人。基础经济学。但这并没有发生。
The doctors just adjusted their criteria for doing stuff and had the patients they had come in more often. Because in health care, supply drives demand. So when the supply of doctors and clinics increases, the demand for medical services goes up. Often, Frank Read says, for a completely innocent reason.
医生们只是调整了他们做事的标准，并让病人更频繁地来看病。因为在医疗保健领域，供给驱动需求。因此，当医生和诊所的供应增加时，对医疗服务的需求就会上升。弗兰克·里德说，通常是因为一个完全无辜的原因。
I don't want to be sitting on my thumbs all the time. I want to be busy. And that may unconsciously loosen my criteria for doing a particular procedure.
我不想一直闲着。我想有事做。这可能会在无意识中让我对做某种特定程序的标准变得宽松。
Which brings us, finally, to the subject, which incredibly, was never ever discussed during the nearly 20 years the doctors met: money. Specifically, the idea that doctors might be prescribing more visits and more procedures so that they could make more money. Frank Read and Bob Keller told me that this subject was completely verboten.
这最终把我们带到了一个在医生们近20年的聚会中从未讨论过的主题：金钱。具体来说，医生可能会为了赚更多的钱而开更多的门诊和手术。弗兰克·里德和鲍勃·凯勒告诉我，这个主题是完全禁止的。
We didn't want to talk about money. That's something that we wouldn't want to acknowledge because it would have been a show stopper. I mean it would have then gone right to the question of greed. And you're not going to keep a doc at the table if you say you're greedy.
我们不想谈钱。那是不想承认的事情，因为那会是一个表演停止器。我的意思是，这会直接引向贪婪的问题。如果你说你是贪婪的，你就没法让一个医生坐在桌边。
Doctors are uncomfortable acknowledging the role of money, but every doctor I talked to admitted, it affects medical decision-making. Including Gordon Smith, head of the Maine Medical Association.
医生们对承认金钱的作用感到不舒服，但我交谈过的每一位医生都承认，它影响医疗决策。包括缅因州医学协会主席戈登·史密斯(Gordon Smith)。
Of course it does. That's just common sense. That's human nature. The payment system is an important influence.
当然有影响。这只是常识。这就是人性。支付系统是一个重要的影响因素。
You see, the majority of doctors in this country are not on salary, but are paid for each thing they do: a la carte. That's what they mean when they say, fee for service. A phrase you've probably heard a lot.
你看，这个国家的多数医生并不是拿薪水，而是为他们做的每一件事付费：点菜式。这就是他们所说的“按服务付费”(fee for service)。这个短语你可能听过很多次。
And the way fee for service affects doctor behavior is clear. Gordon Smith.
而按服务付费影响医生行为的方式很清楚。戈登·史密斯。
If you pay people more the more things they do, they're going to do more things.
如果你付给人们更多的钱，他们做得越多，他们就会做得越多。
Bob Keller points to his own specialty-- he's a back doctor-- and says one of the most popular operations among back doctors these days is this complicated procedure called an instrumented fusion.
鲍勃·凯勒指着他自己的专业——他是一位背部医生——并说现在背部医生中最流行的手术之一是一种叫做“器械融合术”(instrumented fusion)的复杂手术。
When a patient has a back problem, the doctor can go in and insert metal rods. Keller says in the old days the doctor used a much simpler and safer operation, but the new, more complicated one costs more.
当病人有背部问题时，医生可以进去植入金属棒。凯勒说，过去医生使用一种更简单、更安全的手术，但这种新的、更复杂的手术费用更高。
Surgeons could charge more because they were doing these complicated procedures, and so they were putting the screws in. They billed for putting the screws. They were putting the plates in, they billed for putting the plates in. Doing all these things. In the old days a fusion was very much a simpler operation with no external devices. It was all done with the patient's own tissues and bone. So you had a whole new high-tech procedure that was enormously attractive to spine surgeons. And it literally took off in this country.
外科医生可以收取更多费用，因为他们在做这些复杂的手术，所以他们植入了螺丝。他们为植入螺丝收费。他们植入了钢板，他们为植入钢板收费。做所有这些事情。过去，融合术是一种非常简单的手术，没有任何外部装置。一切都是用病人自己的组织和骨头完成的。所以你得到了一种全新的高科技程序，对脊柱外科医生非常有吸引力。它在这个国家确实流行起来了。
At the same time, as most good spine surgeons will admit, they had no research to support what they were doing.
与此同时，正如多数优秀的脊柱外科医生会承认的那样，他们没有任何研究来支持他们所做的事情。
In fact, says Keller, the one high quality study that did exist wasn't so positive.
事实上，凯勒说，确实存在的一项高质量研究并不那么积极。
It showed that it isn't so great actually, as people thought it was. And they also showed that interestingly enough, that the old fashioned non-instrumented fusion was as successful as the instrumented fusion. Which was a real blow.
它显示这实际上并不像人们认为的那么好。而且他们还显示，有趣的是，老式的非器械融合术和器械融合术一样成功。这对我们来说是一个真正的打击。
And here in miniature is one of the big problems with the way our current system is set up. It's a problem some call, more is not better. Doctors exist in a system that encourages-- and really because of their fear of malpractice suits-- actually forces them to do more. More surgery, more tests, more stuff of every kind. And while most Americans just assume that more care is good, it turns out that more isn't always better for patients. Because every time you get a medical procedure, you risk the possibility of complications and doctor error.
这就是我们当前系统设置方式的一个巨大缩影。这是一个有人称之为“多并不更好”(more is not better)的问题。医生存在于一个鼓励——而且由于他们对医疗事故诉讼的恐惧——实际上迫使他们做更多的系统中。更多的手术、更多的检查、更多各种各样的东西。虽然大多数美国人只是假设更多的护理是好的，但事实证明，多并不总是对病人更好。因为每次你接受医疗程序，你都会面临并发症和医生失误的风险。
In 2003, there was this enormous landmark study published by a Jack Wennberg protege named Elliott Fisher. He compared areas throughout the United States. Areas where elderly people got relatively small amounts of health care services to areas where elderly people got a lot of health care services. A lot. Here's Fisher.
2003年，杰克·温伯格的学生埃利奥特·费舍尔(Elliott Fisher)发表了一项巨大的里程碑式研究。他比较了美国各地的地区。老年人获得相对较少医疗服务的地区，与老年人获得大量医疗服务的地区。很多。这是费舍尔。
The patients in the high spending regions were getting about 60% more care. So 60% more days in the hospital, twice as many specialist visits. And yet, when we followed patients for up to five years, the mortality rate whether you were poor or rich, urban or rural, if you lived in one of these higher intensity communities, your survival was certainly no better. And in many cases, worse.
高支出地区的患者获得了约60%以上的护理。即住院天数多了60%，专家门诊次数多了一倍。然而，当我们跟踪随访病人长达五年时，无论你是穷人还是富人、住在城市还是农村，死亡率，如果你生活在这些高强度的社区之一，你的生存率肯定不会更好。在许多情况下，甚至更糟。
After Wennberg's original work in Vermont and Maine, a group of health care researchers set up a shop at Dartmouth College and created something called the Dartmouth Atlas of Health Care. Basically, a countrywide version of what Wennberg did in New England.
在温伯格最初在佛蒙特州和缅因州的工作之后，一群医疗保健研究人员在达特茅斯学院开了一家商店，并创建了所谓《达特茅斯医疗地图集》。基本上，是温伯格在新英格兰所做工作的全国性版本。
The huge warehouse of data compiled by these researchers has led to a lot of insights about our system. Including this very disturbing statistic that you sometimes hear in the health care debate. They've estimated that about one-third of the medical care delivered in this country is unnecessary. One-third. Doctors and hospitals doing things to you and me that we don't need. Stuff that doesn't make us any more healthy. Care delivered by a system that pushes doctors to do more when less is probably better.
这些研究人员汇编的庞大数据仓库导致了对我们系统的许多见解。包括你有时在医改辩论中听到的那个非常令人不安的统计数据。他们估计，这个国家提供的医疗护理中，约有三分之一是不必要的。三分之一。医生和医院对你我做了一些我们不需要的事情。那些没有让我们变得更健康的东西。一个当更少可能更好时，却推动医生做更多的系统所提供的护理。
Alix Spiegel. Coming Up, patients are told that they should do with less. That the test or procedure that they want for themselves is unnecessary. And surprise, they are not too happy about it. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔。稍后，患者被告知他们应该少做检查。他们自己想要的检查或程序是不必要的。令人惊讶的是，他们对此并不太高兴。这将在稍后从芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际的节目中继续播出。
It's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, "More is Less." This is the first of two shows that we're going to be doing, this week and next, explaining the health care system, or parts of it anyway. Today we're asking the question, why are health care costs rising so much that they threaten our entire economy?
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，每周我们都会在我们的节目中选择一个主题，带给你关于这个主题的各种故事。今天的节目，“多即是少”。这是我们将要做的两期节目中的第一期，本周和下周，解释医疗保健体系，或者至少是其中的一部分。今天我们提出这个问题，为什么医疗保健成本上涨得如此厉害，以至于威胁到我们的整个经济？
We've arrived at act two of our show. Act Two: Every Cat Scan Has Nine Lives.
我们已经到了节目的第二幕。第二幕：《每次CT扫描都有九条命》。
This summer at a press conference, President Obama described how he wants to slow the increase in health care costs. He's going to do it by having patients everywhere adjust a bit.
今年夏天在一次新闻发布会上，奥巴马总统描述了他打算如何减缓医疗保健成本的增长。他将通过让各地的病人都做一点调整来做到这一点。
They're going to have to give up paying for things that don't make them healthier. Why would we want to pay for things that don't work?
他们将不得不放弃支付那些不能让他们变得更健康的东西。我们为什么要为那些不起作用的东西买单呢？
Of course when he says it that way it sounds like it could not be easier. According to the Dartmouth Atlas of Health, as you've just heard before the break, one-third of medical spending is on treatments and tests that are not actually necessary. And in some cases, may actually harm us. And President Obama's stimulus package devotes a billion dollars to studying and determining which procedures those are. So, let's just eliminate the stuff that doesn't work, right?
当然，当他那样说时，听起来好像再容易不过了。根据《达特茅斯医疗地图集》，正如你刚才在中断前听到的那样，三分之一的医疗支出是用于实际上没有必要的治疗和检查。在某些情况下，实际上可能伤害我们。奥巴马总统的经济刺激计划投入了十亿美元用于研究和确定哪些程序是这些无用的程序。所以，让我们消除那些不起作用的东西，对吧？
Well, one of our producers, Lisa Pollak, explains why, in practice, that is not so easy to do.
嗯，我们的制作人之一，丽莎·波拉克(Lisa Pollak)，解释了为什么在实践中，这并不容易做到。
In the spirit of the president's advice, here's a story about what happened at one hospital when one doctor tried to resist ordering a test for a patient.
本着总统建议的精神，这是一个关于当一位医生试图拒绝为病人预约检查时，一家医院发生的事情的故事。
The patient was a teenage girl who'd been in a minor car wreck. As a precaution she was brought into the ER on a backboard with one of those collars around her neck. The doctor was Jerome Hoffman. He's a professor of emergency medicine at UCLA. And the first thing he needed to do was rule out the risk of an injury to the girl's cervical spine. He was able to do this without taking an x-ray. Because when he examined the girl, her condition matched this list of five criteria. For instance, she had no tenderness in the middle of the back of her neck that indicate to doctors when a fracture is extremely unlikely.
病人是一个在轻微车祸中的十几岁女孩。作为预防措施，她被带到急诊室，躺在背板上，脖子上戴着那种护颈。医生是杰罗姆·霍夫曼(Jerome Hoffman)。他是加州大学洛杉矶分校(UCLA)的急诊医学教授。他需要做的第一件事是排除女孩颈椎受伤的风险。他无需拍X光片就能做到这一点。因为当他检查那个女孩时，她的状况符合这五个标准列表。例如，她的后颈中部没有触痛，这表明骨折的可能性极小。
Hoffman told the girl's mother that her daughter was fine, no need for an x-ray, and the mother seemed OK with this.
霍夫曼告诉女孩的母亲，她的女儿很好，不需要拍X光片，母亲对此似乎没问题。
But a couple minutes later, the dad showed up.
但几分钟后，父亲出现了。
Dr. Hoffman.
霍夫曼医生。
And the dad was a very tall, very powerful figure, who was very upset and spoke very loudly. And he also happened to mention that he was a lawyer and that there would be consequences for any error that we made. And he said that he wanted to get not just an x-ray, but a CAT scan of her neck.
那位父亲是一个非常高大、非常有权势的人物，他非常心烦意乱，说话声音很大。而且他碰巧提到他是一名律师，并且如果我们犯了任何错误都会有后果。他说他不仅想要拍X光片，还想要做颈部CT扫描。
A CAT scan. Which is not only more expensive than an x-ray, but uses much more radiation.
CT扫描。这不仅比X光片更贵，而且使用了更多的辐射。
So I tried to explain to him that a, she didn't really need the x-ray, or the cat scan. And b, that there was some harm with it. In fact, if you do a thousand CAT scans to a young woman like this, there's a pretty good chance that some small number-- one, two, something like that-- may have harm from it. And the harm is not trivial harm, it's important harm. She could get a cancer of her thyroid that in 15, 20 years might actually be fatal. So while I can't say with 100% certainty that her neck was fine, I was pretty sure-- 99.9% at least, in my judgment, it would be more harmful than beneficial to her to do the test for her.
所以我试图向他解释，a，她真的不需要X光片或CT扫描。b，这确实有一些伤害。事实上，如果你给像这样年轻的女性做一千次CT扫描，很有可能少数——一两次之类的——可能会因此受到伤害。而这种伤害不是微不足道的伤害，而是重要的伤害。她可能会得甲状腺癌，在15、20年后实际上可能是致命的。所以虽然我不能百分之百确定她的脖子很好，但我很确定——根据我的判断，至少有99.9%，为她做这项检查造成的伤害大于益处。
So I tried to explain this to the dad and I tried to be really nice and patient, but he was having none of it. He said things like, you will do a CAT scan. And then I said to him something that, actually I had long known, but it never crystallized for me exactly in this way until that moment.
所以我试图向父亲解释这一点，我试图表现得非常友善和耐心，但他根本听不进去。他说了一些话，比如，你必须做CT扫描。然后我对他说了一些我其实早就知道，但在那一刻之前从未精确地以这种方式结晶出来的话。
I said to him, you know, for me it really is the right thing to do the CAT scan. I said, you know, if I don't do the CAT scan, you're probably going to lodge a complaint about me. If I do the CAT scan, you're going to be really happy with me. I said, in addition, I'm almost certain that your daughter is fine. But there's maybe a one in a million chance that she isn't. That there really is a hidden fracture and I'm missing it. And if that's the case, the CAT scan will save my butt. And on the other hand, if I do the CAT scan and your daughter gets a cancer 20 years from now, no one will blame me. I said, in addition, I'm spending a lot of time talking to you here that I need to be going doing other things. If I get the CAT scan, I could do it in a second. It would be done with. It would be easy.
我对他说，你知道，对我来说，做CT扫描确实是正确的事情。我说，你知道，如果我不做CT扫描，你很可能会投诉我。如果我做了CT扫描，你会对我非常满意。我说，此外，我几乎确定你的女儿没事。但有百万分之一的机会她有事。真的有隐藏的骨折而我漏掉了。如果是那样的话，CT扫描会救我一命。另一方面，如果我做了CT扫描，而你的女儿20年后得了癌症，没人会责怪我。我说，此外，我花了很多时间在这里和你交谈，我还需要去做别的事情。如果我做CT扫描，我可以马上做。它就会完成。那会很容易。
And I said, finally, the really strange thing is that I'll get paid more if I do the CAT scan. Because the way that bills are made, you get paid more for more complex patients. And the insurance companies of the world think that it proves that the patient was more complex and more difficult if you had to do a CAT scan. So everything about this was pushing me to do the CAT scan. I said that to him.
我说，最后，真正奇怪的事情是，如果我做CT扫描，我会得到更多的报酬。因为账单制作的方式，你为更复杂的病人得到的报酬更多。全世界的保险公司认为，如果你不得不做CT扫描，这证明病人更复杂、更难治。所以关于这一切的一切都在推动我去做CT扫描。我对他说。
And I said, there's only one problem, which is that when I decided to become a doctor, I made a pledge. And the pledge was that I would put my patient's interest in front of my own interest. And in this case, my judgment was that it was not in my patient's interest to do the CAT scan. And therefore, I can't do it.
我说，只有一个问题，那就是当我决定成为一名医生时，我做了一个承诺。承诺就是我会把病人的利益放在我自己的利益之前。在这种情况下，我的判断是做CT扫描不符合我病人的利益。因此，我不能做。
And it was really strange. It was interesting because this big guy, very powerful guy who had been really yelling and angry and screaming, his jaw dropped and he was silent. He didn't know what to say.
那真是太奇怪了。这很有趣，因为这个大个子，那个一直大喊大叫、愤怒咆哮的非常有权势的人，他的下巴掉下来了，他沉默了。他不知道说什么好。
And you didn't do the CAT scan?
你没做CT扫描？
Oh no. That was the end of the story. I hope it's the end of the story. It's been over a year now and I haven't gotten that famous embossed letter with the lawsuit, so I'm assuming that everything turned out fine.
哦，没有。那是故事的结尾。我希望这是故事的结尾。已经过去一年多了，我还没有收到那封著名的浮雕印章的诉讼信，所以我假设一切都很顺利。
Hoffman told me this story is not an isolated example. Things like this happen all the time in his department. Whether it's people wanting antibiotics for illnesses that antibiotics have been proven not to help, or tests such as x-rays and CAT scans.
霍夫曼告诉我，这个故事并不是一个孤立的例子。这样的事情在他的科室里经常发生。无论是人们想要抗生素治疗抗生素被证明无效的疾病，还是像X光和CT扫描这样的检查。
Where  a patient thinks, well, don't I need to be sure that I don't have appendicitis? Or this, that, or the other thing. And really, the right thing for the doctor to do is to think. And in many cases, not to do any tests. At least not right now. There's a place for tests and there's a place for interventions. But not in every case. And yet, the incentive to the doctor is often, just do everything.
当一个病人想，嗯，难道我不该确定我没有阑尾炎吗？或者这个、那个、或其它什么事情。真正正确的事情是医生去思考。在许多情况下，什么检查也不要做。至少现在不要。检查有其地位，介入有其地位。但不是在每一种情况下。然而，给医生的激励往往是，做所有的事情。
And the truth is, a lot of us like it that way. It's hard to understand how doing everything could be bad for us. We think, better safe than sorry. Do everything possible.
事实是，我们许多人喜欢那样。很难理解为什么“做一切”对我们有害。我们想，宁可谨慎也不要遗憾。做一切可能的事。
In a study published earlier this year, half the public believes someone's getting unnecessary health care. But only 16% thought it was them. We're so wired to think that more health care is better that when someone suggests we might be better off with less, it's upsetting.
在今年早些时候发表的一项研究中，一半的公众相信有人获得了不必要的医疗护理。但只有16%的人认为那是他们自己。我们的大脑被设定为认为更多的医疗保健更好，所以当有人建议我们少做一点可能会更好时，这令人不安。
Even daring to raise the question, is this device or test or pill really making us healthier, can send people into a panic.
甚至敢于提出这个问题，这个设备、检查或药丸是否真的让我们更健康，就能让人陷入恐慌。
Consider the PSA test, the blood test used to screen men for prostate cancer. The question of whether the benefits of this test outweigh the risks is one of the most controversial issues in medicine. Some doctors worry that the test is leading to unnecessary treatment. Because it catches many prostate cancers that are so slow growing they would never be harmful if left alone.
考虑一下PSA检查，用于筛查男性前列腺癌的血液检查。这项检查的益处是否超过风险的问题是医学中最具争议的问题之一。一些医生担心这项检查会导致不必要的治疗。因为它捕捉到了许多前列腺癌，这些癌症生长如此缓慢，如果不去管它，永远不会有害。
In 2002, two medical journal editors, both doctors, made this point in an op-ed for the San Francisco Chronicle . Gavin Yamey and Michael Wilkes wrote that since early detection hadn't been proven through randomized control trials to reduce a man's risk of dying from prostate cancer, getting the test might not be right for every man. Their op-ed, published under the headline, "Prostate Cancer Screening: Is It Worth the Pain," did not go over so well.
2002年，两位医学期刊编辑，都是医生，在《旧金山纪事报》的一篇社论中提出了这一点。加文·亚米(Gavin Yamey)和迈克尔·威尔克斯(Michael Wilkes)写道，由于早期发现并未通过随机对照试验被证明能降低男性死于前列腺癌的风险，所以并不是每个男性都应该进行检查。他们的社论标题是“前列腺癌筛查：值得这种痛苦吗”，结果并不太好。
Lots of people wished that we would die.
很多人希望我们死。
That's Gavin Yamey. Since many of the readers believed the PSA test had saved their lives, they didn't appreciate being told that the test wasn't effective.
那是加文·亚米。因为许多读者认为PSA检查救了他们的命，他们不欣赏被告知这项检查并不有效。
Lots of people wished we would have a very slow death from a nasty cancer. People accused us of having the deaths of thousands of men on our hands for writing this piece. Of geriatricide.
很多人希望我们因为写了这篇文章而缓慢地死于讨厌的癌症。人们指责我们手上沾满了数千名男性的死亡。指责我们犯了老年杀戮罪。
Michael Wilkes, Yamey's co-author.
迈克尔·威尔克斯，亚米的合著者。
People wrote both to us and to our bosses accusing us of being sort of like the Nazis. And specifically, accusing us of being like Mengele. Others accusing us of truly being men-haters and wanting to wipe out the male population.
人们写信给我们和我们的老板，指责我们像纳粹一样。特别是指责我们像门格勒。其他人指责我们是真正的厌男者，想要消灭男性人口。
When the president says we can cut health care costs by eliminating things that don't work, things for which there's no evidence, it sidesteps the fact that in medicine the evidence isn't always so clear cut. And that's true with the PSA test.
当总统说我们可以通过消除那些不起作用的东西，那些没有任何证据支持的东西来削减医疗保健成本时，这回避了一个事实，即在医学中证据并不总是那么清晰。对于PSA检查也是如此。
There's a lot more evidence about PSA now than there was when Yamey and Wilkes wrote their op-ed. In fact, two long-awaited studies came out this Spring.
现在关于PSA的证据比亚米和威尔克斯写那篇社论时要多得多。事实上，今年春天发布了两项期待已久的研究。
One showed that the PSA test did not reduce a man's risk of dying from prostate cancer. The other showed it reduced prostate cancer deaths by 20%. But it also showed that for every life saved because of PSA screening, 48 other men were diagnosed and treated. In other words, for each prostate cancer death prevented, dozens of men endured surgery or radiation, risking serious side effects, like impotence and incontinence.
一项研究表明，PSA检查并没有降低男性死于前列腺癌的风险。另一项显示它将前列腺癌死亡率降低了20%。但它也显示，因为PSA筛查而挽救的每一个生命，有48名其他男性被诊断和治疗。换句话说，每预防一个前列腺癌死亡，几十名男性忍受了手术或放疗，冒着严重的副作用风险，比如阳痿和失禁。
Doctors interpret this evidence differently. Some I talked to said it's proof that the test saves lives. Others said it shows we might be hurting more men than we're helping. Because the evidence is ambiguous and the balance of risks and benefits is really a judgment call, most national guidelines say that doctors should let men know the pros and cons of PSA testing, and let them decide whether to have it. But most of the time this is not what happens. Studies show that the majority of men get the test without any discussion at all. It's automatic, a no-brainer. And honestly, it's not hard to see why.
医生对这些证据的解读不同。我采访的一些人说这是检查挽救生命的证据。其他人说这表明我们可能伤害的男性比我们帮助的多。因为证据是模糊的，风险和益处的平衡确实是一个判断问题，大多数国家指南说医生应该让男性知道PSA检查的利弊，让他们决定是否进行检查。但大多数时候情况并非如此。研究表明，多数男性在没有任何讨论的情况下就进行了检查。这是自动的，是不言自明的。老实说，不难看出原因。
To question whether the test is necessary, a doctor is flying in the face of all sorts of cultural forces. Like the idea that if you can find cancer early, you always should. Not to mention all the billboards and free PSA screening events and celebrities in TV ads telling men to get tested.
要质疑这项检查是否必要，医生是在对抗各种文化力量。比如如果你能及早发现癌症，你就应该去做。更不用说所有的广告牌、免费PSA筛查活动和电视广告中的名人告诉男性去检查。
Want to do something really special for your man this Christmas? Call his doctor and schedule his prostate exam. Prostate exams save lives and prostates.
今年圣诞节想为你的男人做点特别的事情吗？打电话给他的医生，安排他的前列腺检查。前列腺检查挽救生命和前列腺。
Here's another from the NFL.
这是来自NFL的另一个。
So get screened and don't let prostate cancer take you out of the game.
所以接受筛查，不要让前列腺癌把你踢出比赛。
And of course, Larry King.
当然还有拉里·金(Larry King)。
Men over 40, take your PSA test. It's a simple, little blood test. You get the result in a couple days.
40岁以上的男人，做你的PSA检查。这是一个简单的、小小的血液检查。你几天内就能得到结果。
A few doctors I talked to mentioned another reason that physicians might be wary of bucking the PSA trend. They told me what happened to a doctor named Dan Merenstein.
我采访的几位医生提到了医生可能对违抗PSA趋势持谨慎态度的另一个原因。他们告诉我一位名叫丹·梅伦斯坦(Dan Merenstein)的医生发生了什么。
Merenstein was trained in evidence-based medicine, and about 10 years ago, when he was a family practice resident, a 53-year-old man came to him for a routine physical. Merenstein says he followed the guidelines. Talked to the patient about the benefits and risks of getting the PSA test. And the man chose not to have it. Then, a year and a half later, the man went to another doctor. That doctor tested the man's blood without discussing it with him. His PSA level was extremely high and a biopsy found an aggressive, incurable cancer.
梅伦斯坦受过循证医学训练，大约10年前，当他还是家庭医生住院医师时，一名53岁的男子来找他做常规体检。梅伦斯坦说他遵循了指导方针。与病人讨论了进行PSA检查的利弊。那个人选择不做。然后，一年半后，那个人去了另一位医生那里。那位医生在没有与他讨论的情况下检查了他的血液。他的PSA水平极高，活检发现了一种侵袭性的、不可治愈的癌症。
Now there is was proof that having an earlier PSA test would have changed the man's fate. But Merenstein and his residency program were sued for malpractice. At the trial, the patient's attorney argued that Merenstein shouldn't have given the man a choice to have the PSA test, no matter what the national guideline said. The attorney put other family doctors on the stand.
现在有证据表明，如果早点做PSA检查会改变那个人的命运。但梅伦斯坦和他的住院医师项目因医疗事故被起诉。在审判中，病人的律师辩称，梅伦斯坦不应该给那个人选择做PSA检查的机会，无论国家指南怎么说。律师把其他家庭医生推上了证人席。
And they said, you know, we don't talk to patients.
他们说，你知道，我们不和病人讨论。
This is Dr. Merenstein.
这是梅伦斯坦医生。
That's what they do in ivory towers. You know, I order tests. Patients come to me for me to order the test. I'm the one that went to medical school. And these are the tests we order. And if Dr. Merenstein had ordered this-- they said this straight under oath. And if Dr. Merenstein had ordered a PSA, this patient would live a long, productive life. But because Dr. Merenstein failed to, this patient is going to die surely.
那是他们在象牙塔里做的事情。你知道，我预约检查。病人来找我就是让我预约检查。我是那个上医学院的人。这就是我们预约的检查。如果梅伦斯坦医生预约了这个——他们宣誓后直截了当地说。如果梅伦斯坦医生预约了PSA，这个病人就会过上长久、高产的生活。但因为梅伦斯坦医生没有，这个病人肯定会死。
Merenstein was exonerated, but his residency program was found liable for a million dollars. The jury, just like the doctors on the stand, rejected the idea of following the guidelines based on evidence. To them, the best care meant doing everything you can.
梅伦斯坦被免除了责任，但他的住院医师项目被判承担一百万美元的赔偿责任。陪审团，就像证人席上的医生一样，拒绝了遵循基于证据的指南的想法。对他们来说，最好的护理意味着尽你所能去做一切。
I should have just ordered it. There should have been no discussion. It shouldn't have been up to the patient. So that was the approach they took. And they took this approach that this thing called evidence-based medicine is just a way to save money, just a way to ration care.
我应该直接预约它。不应该有讨论。这不应该由病人决定。所以那是他们采取的方法。他们采取这种方法，认为所谓的循证医学只是节省开支的一种方式，只是分配医疗的一种方式。
After the trial, like a lot of doctors who had been sued, Merenstein found it hard not to see patients as potential plaintiffs.
审判后，像许多被起诉过的医生一样，梅伦斯坦发现很难不把病人看作潜在的原告。
I think you view people differently after that and you look at patients and you say, this mole, which a thousand times before I would say I'm pretty confident on how to evaluate moles and which ones I need to take off myself, and which ones I think are fine to stay, and which ones need to go. You know, I think I started sending more moles to dermatologists to remove and sending more people with what I was pretty confident was irritable bowel or something like that to GI doctors to get scoped and things like that more than I should have. It sort of just didn't feel right.
我认为在那之后你以不同的方式看待人们，你看着病人然后说，这颗痣，以前一千次我会说我有信心评估痣，哪些我需要自己切除，哪些我认为没事可以留着，哪些需要去掉。你知道，我想我开始把更多的痣送到皮肤科医生那里去切除，并把更多有我相当确信是肠易激综合征或类似情况的人送到消化科医生那里去做镜检，比我应该做的次数多。这感觉有点不对。
It didn't feel right, he said, because it didn't feel like he was doing what was best for the patients. These days, when it comes to the PSA test, Merenstein starts by following the evidence. He still tells his patients the pros and cons, but then he gives them a little nudge and adds something he never used to. "Most people," he tells his patients, "get the test."
他说这感觉不对，因为他觉得他没有为病人做最好的事情。这些日子，当涉及到PSA检查时，梅伦斯坦首先遵循证据。他仍然告诉他的病人利弊，但他会给他们一点推动，并加上他以前从未做过的事情。“大多数人，”他告诉他的病人，“都做了这项检查。”
Lisa Pollak. If you're a man and you heard this story and you want to know more about the pros and cons of getting the PSA test, there's a good summary at the Mayo Clinic web site. Those people really know what they're doing.
丽莎·波拉克。如果你是一名男性，听了这个故事，想了解更多关于PSA检查利弊的信息，梅奥诊所(Mayo Clinic)的网站上有一个很好的总结。那些人确实很了解他们在做什么。
Act 3, Who Would Win in a Fight Between a Polar Bear and an Insurance Company?
第三幕：《北极熊和保险公司打架谁会赢？》
So if doctors aren't going to keep costs down and patients aren't going to keep costs down, how about insurance companies? Out of everybody in the health care system, you would think that this would be the one group most interested in keeping costs down because they are the ones who actually make the payments to doctors and hospitals, and every dollar they save is basically a dollar they get to keep. A dollar that goes into their profits. Or, if you want to get very technical about this, it's a dollar less that they could charge you and me in premiums.
所以如果医生不去降低成本，病人也不去降低成本，那么保险公司呢？在医疗保健系统中的每一个人中，你会认为这是最关心降低成本的一群人，因为他们才是实际向医生和医院付款的人，他们节省的每一美元基本上都是他们可以留下的。流向他们利润的一美元。或者，如果你想对此非常技术性地说，这是他们可以减少在你我保费中收取的一美元。
Well, we looked into this and it turns out that there are a lot of reasons that insurance companies have a hard time holding down health care costs. But they all boil down to one thing. Insurance companies are not always as powerful as you would think.
好吧，我们调查了这一点，结果发现保险公司难以控制医疗保健成本的原因有很多。但它们都归结为一件事。保险公司并不总是像你想象的那样强大。
The way that insurance works is that each insurance company makes its own contract, its own deal, with each local hospital group or health provider system. And that deal spells out how much the insurance company is going to reimburse for every different kind of procedure and test. And even in cities where a company is the biggest insurer in the market, even then, it does not necessarily have the power to boss hospitals around and push down costs and bargain down prices.
保险运作的方式是，每家保险公司都与当地的每个医院集团或医疗提供系统订立自己的合同，达成自己的协议。而那份协议规定了保险公司将为每种不同类型的程序和检查补偿多少。即使是在公司是市场上最大的保险商的城市，即使那样，它也不一定有权力命令医院到处乱跑，压低成本和讨价还价。
Take, as an example, the pricing showdown between Blue Cross of California-- huge insurance company-- and this big network of hospitals and clinics called Sutter Health. Sarah Koenig, another one of our producers, tells what happened.
举个例子，加州蓝十字(Blue Cross of California)——巨大的保险公司——和这个叫做萨特健康(Sutter Health)的大型医院和诊所网络之间的定价对决。萨拉·科尼格(Sarah Koenig)，我们的另一位制作人，讲述了发生了什么。
Back in 2000, Sutter was demanding huge rate increases from Blue Cross, averaging something like 30% or 35%. That was a shocker. Blue Cross was the biggest insurer in the state, which meant it was used to getting cheaper rates from hospitals than the smaller guys.
早在2000年，萨特就要求蓝十字大幅提价，平均涨幅大约在30%或35%左右。那是一个令人震惊的消息。蓝十字是该州最大的保险商，这意味着它习惯于从医院获得比小公司更便宜的价格。
But Sutter was enormous too. It had more than a hundred health care facilities all over Northern California, including more than two dozen hospitals. Sutter had what's called a geographic lock on the Bay Area. So of the several hundred thousand Blue Cross customers there--
但萨特也庞大无比。它在北加州拥有超过一百家医疗保健设施，包括两打以上的医院。萨特拥有所谓的对湾区的“地理锁定”。所以那里的几十万蓝十字客户中——
Almost everybody received, or knew, or went to Sutter for their medical care.
几乎每个人都接受，或知道，或去萨特寻求医疗护理。
That's Michael Chee. At the time, he was spokesman for Blue Cross of California. And Blue Cross's position was that Sutter's demands were out of line. They weren't justified by the medical costs and inflation data Blue Cross had researched. So Blue Cross offered a lower figure. Sutter rejected it, saying Blue Cross had been underpaying them for years. It got contentious. Blue Cross still refused to pay. So Sutter said, if you don't, you can tell your members to go elsewhere, find other doctors, go to other hospitals.
那是迈克尔·奇(Michael Chee)。当时，他是加州蓝十字的发言人。而蓝十字的立场是，萨特的要求是不合规的。它们并没有被蓝十字研究过的医疗成本和通胀数据所证明。所以蓝十字提供了一个更低的数字。萨特拒绝了，说蓝十字多年来一直少付他们钱。这变得有争议了。蓝十字仍然拒绝支付。所以萨特说，如果你不付，你可以告诉你的会员去别处，找别的医生，去别的医院。
The brinksmanship that kind of occurred was, well, if we close our doors, all these people-- hundreds of thousands of them-- are going to be forced to travel an extra 30 minutes, an extra 10 miles, and that was not acceptable to the membership. So the membership began to express its opinion in the negotiations.
那种发生的边缘政策是，好吧，如果我们关门，所有这些人——几十万人——将被迫多跑30分钟，多跑10英里，这对会员来说是不可接受的。所以会员开始在谈判中表达他们的意见。
Blue Cross got dozens, sometimes hundreds of phone calls a day, all thanks to a new pressure tactic used by Sutter. Sutter urged its patients to call Blue Cross's customer service line and complain. Michael Chee and his bosses started seeing news stories about the dispute, stories that favored Sutter. In response, Blue Cross launched a major marketing push of its own to try to convince customers everything would be OK if they would just find different doctors.
蓝十字每天接到几十个，有时几百个电话，多亏了萨特使用的一种新的压力策略。萨特敦促其病人给蓝十字的客户服务热线打电话投诉。迈克尔·奇和他的老板开始看到关于纠纷的新闻报道，倾向于萨特的报道。作为回应，蓝十字发起了自己的一次重大营销推动，试图说服客户如果他们只是找到不同的医生，一切都会没事的。
Michael Chee did interviews with reporters. He sent tens of thousands of letters to Blue Cross members saying things like, "We are saddened and disappointed that Sutter has put its energy into instigating members like you to contact us."
迈克尔·奇接受了记者的采访。他给蓝十字会员寄出了几万封信，内容是这样的：“我们感到难过和失望的是，萨特把精力放在煽动像您这样的会员联系我们上。”
Blue Cross bought ads in local newspapers, publishing lists of non-Sutter care centers, explaining who all the doctors were and what they specialized in. And pointing out that those facilities weren't much farther than Sutter's.
蓝十字在当地报纸上买了广告，发布非萨特医疗中心的名单，解释所有医生是谁以及他们擅长什么。并指出那些设施离萨特并不远。
So you guys sort of mounted this campaign to try to convince your membership, we can do this, we can live without Sutter? They came back to you and said--
所以你们这种人试图说服你们的会员，我们可以做到，我们可以没有萨特生活？他们回来对你们说——
And said, I can't live without Sutter. You know, we want what we want. I've been with my doctor here at this location for many years, and I don't want to have to look for somebody new. I don't want to have to make any extra effort.
并且说，我没有萨特没法生活。你知道，我们想要我们想要的。我和我的医生在这个位置已经很多年了，我不想必须去找新人。我不想必须做任何额外的努力。
I mean did you explain, as a company also, like this is potentially going to cost you guys more because your premiums are going to go up?
我的意思是，作为一个公司，你们也解释了吗，这可能导致你们的成本增加，因为保费会上升？
Absolutely. Absolutely. One of the things we tried to tell members and employers was, this is our job. Our job is to control health care costs, so that your premiums don't constantly go up. So that you're not constantly paying more. And one of the ways we do that is by these negotiations.
绝对的。绝对的。我们试图告诉会员和雇主的事情之一是，这是我们的工作。我们的工作是控制医疗保健成本，这样你们的保费就不会不断上升。这样你们就不会不断支付更多。而我们那样做的方法之一就是通过这些谈判。
None of this worked. Customers didn't budge. Neither did anybody else. State lawmakers got dragged into the fight to mediate. Finally, because they couldn't live without each other, Sutter and Blue Cross worked out a compromise. Sutter didn't get all the money it asked for. It wasn't a 30% increase. The actual number wasn't made public. But they got enough that it resulted in hiked up premiums. That's one reason medical costs in San Francisco, where Sutter is totally dominant, are still more expensive than cities nearby, like Oakland and San Jose, where Sutter isn't quite as strong. So that now a family of four in San Francisco pays $45 more per month to Blue Cross than it would pay in San Jose for exactly the same coverage.
这一切都没有奏效。客户没有动摇。其他人也没有。州议员被拉入斗争中进行调解。最后，因为他们无法离开对方生活，萨特和蓝十字达成了一个妥协。萨特没有得到它要求的所有钱。那不是30%的增长。实际数字没有公开。但他们得到的足够多，以至于导致了保费上涨。这就是旧金山的医疗成本——萨特在旧金山完全占主导地位——仍然比附近的城市，比如奥克兰和圣何塞，那里萨特并没有那么强，要更昂贵的一个原因。所以现在旧金山的一个四口之家每月向蓝十字支付的费用比在圣何塞支付同样的覆盖范围多45美元。
Michael Chee is still sort of baffled that it worked out this way. That people don't respond to bottom line reasoning when it comes to where and how they get care. He says costs will keep rising until we consumers start sacrificing a little, making different health care choices.
迈克尔·奇仍然对他感到困惑，事情竟然是这样发展的。当涉及到他们去哪里以及如何获得医疗护理时，人们对底线推理没有反应。他说，成本将继续上升，直到我们消费者开始牺牲一点，做出不同的医疗选择。
Based on knowledge, based on facts, not based on our feelings, not based on what we want. Without those kinds of sacrifices, we're always going to be stuck in this argument of, I want what I want, and what I want can be very expensive and not the most cost effective thing.
基于知识，基于事实，不是基于我们的感觉，不是基于我们想要的。没有那种牺牲，我们永远会陷入这种论点：我想要我想要的，而我想要的可能非常昂贵，而且不是最符合成本效益的事情。
As it happened, I interviewed Michael Chee from the hospital. He'd had an accident involving one of those jet ski things and suffered a head trauma.
碰巧，我从医院采访了迈克尔·奇。他发生了一起涉及那种喷气滑雪板之类的事故，并遭受了脑外伤。
Natasha Richardson had a very similar injury to mine. Mine was probably actually more severe. Quite honestly, I shouldn't be talking to you right now. I should be dead.
娜塔莎·理查森(Natasha Richardson)受到的伤害与我很相似。我的可能实际上更严重。老实说，我现在不应该和你说话。我应该已经死了。
Michael Chee lives in Burbank, California, near Los Angeles. But he had the accident on the Colorado River in Nevada and was airlifted to Las Vegas for treatment. For his two week rehab, he wanted to go home to LA, and had been arguing about that with his insurance company. Which happens to be Blue Cross.
迈克尔·奇住在洛杉矶附近的加州伯班克。但他是在内华达州的科罗拉多河发生的事故，并被空运到拉斯维加斯接受治疗。对于他两周的康复，他想回洛杉矶的家，并一直在与他的保险公司争论。那刚好是蓝十字。
There are providers that I have a preference for closer to home, closer to where I live, that I wanted to go to for my care because I know them, I trust them. But my insurance would not accommodate my medical transport from here to there because those rehab services were available right here without having to move me.
有我偏好的靠近家、靠近我住的地方的医疗提供者，我想去那里接受我的护理，因为我认识他们，我信任他们。但我的保险无法协调我从这里到那里的医疗运输，因为那些康复服务就在这里提供，而不必移动我。
But Wait, weren't you just making the exact opposite argument before, that patients should be willing to sacrifice for lower costs and quality care?
等等，你刚才不是在做完全相反的论点吗，即病人应该愿意为更低的成本和优质的医疗牺牲？
So here I am, away from home for two weeks getting my rehabilitation done. Yes. I mean when you're injured and you have the kind of injury that I have, you want to be close friends and family because it's just more comforting. That doesn't mean that's a smart medical decision. That just means that's what I want emotionally.
所以我就在这里，离家两周做我的康复。是的。我的意思是，当你受伤，并且你有我那种伤害时，你想要靠近朋友和家人，因为那更令人安慰。这并不意味着那是一个明智的医疗决定。这只是意味着在情感上那是我想想要的。
I know, I know. But hearing this, you completely-- your sympathies are completely with the patient. You just think, of course you want to go home and be around your friends and family. And you've had this traumatic thing happen and it's totally upsetting, and probably very frightening. And of course, you want to go home. You know what I mean? I think it's a real dilemma.
我知道，我知道。但听到这个，你完全——你的同情心完全在于病人。你只是想，当然你想回家和你的朋友家人在一起。你遭受了这种创伤性的事情，这完全令人不安，而且可能非常可怕。当然，你想回家。你知道我的意思吗？我认为这是一个真正的两难境地。
It is a dilemma. And I felt that. And I went through that entire emotional process.
这是一个两难境地。我感觉到了。我经历了整个情感过程。
Do you think Blue Cross has made the right decision in your case?
你认为蓝十字在你这件事上做出了正确的决定吗？
I think so. From a cost standpoint, yes.
我认为是的。从成本的角度来看，是的。
We probably can all agree that Blue Cross made the right choice in trying to save money on Michael Chee. But we agree only in the cold light of day. And that's what I mean by the dilemma. As patients, we don't usually consider things in the cold light of day. It's no wonder we don't respond to pocketbook arguments about how to save money on our own care. And that's partly what makes us, the patients, a secret weapon in these negotiations. At least for the doctors and hospitals. Because we side with them every time. Because we like our doctors. We trust them. We basically hate our insurers, even though the insurers are paid to represent us in negotiating the price of our own care. And we unwittingly side with the doctors in another battle we don't even know is going on between doctors and insurers. The one about eliminating unnecessary medical services and procedures.
我们可能都能同意蓝十字在试图为迈克尔·奇省钱这件事上做出了正确的选择。但我们只有在白天的冷光下才同意。而这就是我所说的两难境地。作为病人，我们通常不会在白天的冷光下考虑事情。难怪我们对如何节省自己护理费用的钱夹论点没有反应。而这部分使得我们——病人——成为这些谈判中的秘密武器。至少对于医生和医院来说是这样。因为我们每次都站在他们那边。因为我们喜欢我们的医生。我们信任他们。我们基本上讨厌我们的保险商，即使保险商被支付来代表我们谈判我们自己护理的价格。而且我们在医生和保险商之间进行的另一场我们甚至不知道发生了什么的战斗中，无意中站在了医生那边。关于消除不必要医疗服务和程序的战斗。
As you heard earlier in the show, the Dartmouth Health Atlas estimates about a third of every health care dollar we spend is wasted on tests and treatment we don't need. So if health insurance companies know they're shelling out all that money on stuff that isn't necessary, why can't they do something about it? I put this to Jack Rowe, the former CEO of Aetna, one of the biggest health insurers in the country.
正如你在节目早些时候听到的，达特茅斯健康地图集估计我们花费的每一美元医疗保健中约有三分之一被浪费在不需要的检查和治疗上。所以，如果医疗保险公司知道他们把所有的钱都花在不必要的东西上，为什么他们不能对此做点什么？我把这个问题抛给了杰克·罗(Jack Rowe)，安泰保险(Aetna)的前CEO，该国最大的医疗保险商之一。
When he was in charge, he watched Aetna's expenses and its profits very, very carefully.
当他负责时，他非常、非常仔细地观察了安泰的开支及其利润。
Why doesn't an insurance company go, I want that 30% to 40%? You know what I mean? It seems like this is a lot of money sitting there that you guys could profit from. Is there any way to get at that percentage?
为什么保险公司不去，我想要那30%到40%？你知道我的意思吗？看起来有很多钱坐在那里，你们可以从中获利。有什么办法能得到那个百分比吗？
Insurance companies are trying very hard to develop approaches, which will not only improve quality but reduce overuse.
保险公司正在非常努力地开发方法，这不仅将提高质量，而且将减少过度使用。
So they're trying, and it's true, Aetna has all kinds of programs. Good, money-saving programs to promote cheaper drugs, to make sure diabetics and cardiac patients do all the preventative things to keep them out of the emergency room. Plus Aetna, like all insurance companies, has guidelines for new technologies they will and won't cover. And all the scientific studies that back up that policy. But the fact is, if companies like Aetna say no too often, they risk losing customers.
所以他们正在尝试，这是真的，安泰有各种各样的计划。好的、省钱的计划，以推广更便宜的药物，以确保糖尿病和心脏病患者做所有预防性的事情，让他们远离急诊室。另外，安泰，像所有保险公司一样，对于他们将覆盖和不覆盖的新技术有指南。以及支持该政策的所有科学研究。但事实是，如果像安泰这样的公司说“不”太频繁，他们冒着失去客户的风险。
So there's great sensitivity over that because physicians say that the insurance companies are practicing medicine. And who are they to tell me whether or not this patient needs this operation? As you recall, that's one of the things that led to the great pushback.
所以对此非常敏感，因为医生说保险公司在从事医学。他们是谁，来告诉我这个病人是否需要这个手术？如你所记得的，那是导致巨大回击的事情之一。
The great pushback, also known in the insurance industry as the backlash. He's talking about HMOs.
巨大的回击，在保险业中也称为“反弹”(backlash)。他说的是HMO（健康维护组织）。
Back in the 1980s, employers went to insurance companies and pleaded with them to keep down costs. And that's when the HMO came into vogue. By the mid '90s, most employers used HMOs to cover their employees. And it pretty much worked. Health care costs stopped rising for the first time in a long time. One year they even fell. But a big part of keeping costs down was tightly controlling which doctors patients could see, and denying coverage for procedures that doctors argued were necessary. Insurance companies were inundated with complaints.
早在1980年代，雇主去保险公司恳求他们控制成本。而那时HMO开始流行。到了90年代中期，多数雇主使用HMO来覆盖他们的员工。而它几乎奏效了。医疗保健成本在很长一段时间内第一次停止上涨。有一年它们甚至下降了。但控制成本的很大一部分是严格控制病人能看哪些医生，并拒绝覆盖医生争论说必要的程序。保险公司被投诉淹没了。
From physicians, and hospitals, also from patients who were getting complaints from physicians about their insurers. Politicians. Also we're getting complaints from doctors, and hospitals, and patients.
来自医生和医院，也来自从医生那里得到关于他们保险商投诉的病人。政治家。也从医生、医院和病人那里得到投诉。
There were dramatic stories in the press about people who'd been denied lifesaving operations. There were class action lawsuits, legislation to limit their powers. Then there was that Helen Hunt movie. Remember, As Good As It Gets , where she plays the mother of this poor asthmatic boy who needed some tests he didn't get.
媒体上有关于被拒绝救命手术的人的戏剧性故事。有集体诉讼，限制他们权力的立法。然后还有那部海伦·亨特(Helen Hunt)的电影。记得吗，《尽善尽美》(As Good As It Gets)，她在那里扮演那个贫穷的哮喘男孩的母亲，他需要一些他没得到的检查。
They said my plan didn't cover it and that it wasn't necessary anyways. Why, should they have?
他们说我的计划不覆盖它，而且无论如何它没必要。为什么，他们应该覆盖吗？
Well.
嗯。
[BLEEP] HMO, bastard pieces of [BLEEP] OK, I'm sorry.
（哔）HMO，杂种碎片（哔）好的，我很抱歉。
It's OK. Actually, I think that's their technical name.
没关系。其实，我认为那是他们的技术名称。
Jack Rowe was one of two insurance executives I talked to who mentioned that movie. It left a big impression on the insurance industry. Because when people saw it in the theaters, they reportedly broke into applause.
杰克·罗是我采访的两位提到那部电影的保险高管之一。它给保险业留下了深刻的印象。因为当人们在电影院看到它时，据说他们爆发了掌声。
As a result of those years of opposition, insurance companies will only fight doctors and patients to a point. They don't want to go back to the days of the HMOs, of being the hard-asses telling everyone no. Even though they did successfully hold down costs back then. And they did it without making people sicker. There were anecdotal horror stories for sure. But overall, as a country, our medical care didn't suffer. We were just as healthy. But that's not how we remember it.
作为那些年反对的结果，保险公司只会为了一个点而与医生和病人斗争。他们不想回到HMO的日子，做那个对每个人说“不”的硬汉。即使他们当时确实成功地控制了成本。而且他们这样做并没有让人们变得更糟。当然有轶事般的恐怖故事。但总的来说，作为一个国家，我们的医疗护理并没有受到影响。我们一样健康。但那不是我们记忆中的样子。
And now you always hear, no one should stand between you and your doctor.
而且现在你总是听到，没有人应该站在你和你的医生之间。
This is Uwe Reinhardt, a health care economist at Princeton university.
这是乌韦·莱因哈特(Uwe Reinhardt)，普林斯顿大学的医疗保健经济学家。
You know what that means? That means no one should ever control utilization, even if it's unnecessary. If your doctor thinks it's necessary, no one should ever say no. And almost anyone who's looked at the data says, oh yes, somebody should.
你知道那意味着什么吗？这意味着没有人应该控制使用量，即使它是不必要的。如果你的医生认为它是必要的，没有人应该说不。而几乎任何看过数据的人都说，哦，是的，应该有人说。
According to Reinhardt, the fact that insurers can't completely crack down on unnecessary procedures is just one of a whole host of reasons why the insurance industry really can't control costs in the American health care system right now.
根据莱因哈特的说法，保险公司不能完全严厉打击不必要程序的事实，只是为什么医疗保险业现在真的无法控制美国医疗保健体系成本的诸多原因中的一个。
Do insurance companies actually have an incentive to keep costs down?
保险公司实际上有动机控制成本吗？
I've often asked myself that question. Obviously, when you compete against another insurers, it's good to have lower premiums. But the insurance industry as a whole, basically, their profits tend to be 3% to 5% of whatever money flows through their books. So the more money flows through the books, the more profit they make.
我经常问自己那个问题。显然，当你与其它保险商竞争时，拥有更低的保费是好的。但保险业作为一个整体，基本上，他们的利润往往是流过他们账面资金的3%到5%。所以流过账面的钱越多，他们赚的利润就越多。
Suppose a guard waved a magic wand and said, OK, now health care costs in America are half of what they are now. Then the insurance industry's book of business would be half of what it is now, and therefore, their profits would be half of what it is now. It's not totally clear to me the insurance industry would love that.
假设一个守卫挥动魔杖说，好的，现在美国的医疗保健成本是现在的一半。那么保险业的业务书将是现在的一半，因此，他们的利润将是现在的一半。我不完全确定保险业会喜欢那样。
As it stands, insurance companies are doing pretty well. They don't make anything close to the 30% profits of, say, Microsoft, or Merck Pharmaceuticals. Or even the 10% profits of Exxon Mobil, but Fortune magazine lists the health insurance industry as the 35th most profitable industry in the country based on 2008 revenue.
目前，保险公司表现相当不错。他们赚的钱远不及微软或默克制药(Merck Pharmaceuticals)那30%的利润。甚至不及埃克森美孚(Exxon Mobil)那10%的利润，但《财富》杂志根据2008年的收入将医疗保险业列为该国第35大盈利行业。
What's the 34th most profitable industry you ask, just above the insurers? That would be medical facilities.
你问第34大盈利行业是什么，就在保险商之上？那将是医疗设施。
Sarah Koenig.
萨拉·科尼格。
Act Now What? OK, so far this hour we've illustrated just some of the main things that are driving up health care costs. And truthfully, putting this show together over the last few months, it's been hard not to get sort of depressed. Not only do the problems seem like they're built into the very foundation of our health care system, but the health reform debate that's going on right now in Washington doesn't seem to be about cutting costs at all. Democrats and republicans are arguing over who's going to get insurance, and public option, and how it's paid for. Not to mention death panels and abortion. There's really not much discussion about how to fix the health care system as a whole to slow the runaway costs that threaten our entire economy. The stuff we've been talking about all this hour.
《现在怎么办？》好的，到目前为止这一个小时我们已经说明了推动医疗保健成本上升的一些主要事情。老实说，在过去的几个月里，把这个节目放在一起，很难不变得有些沮丧。不仅问题看起来像是建立在我们医疗保健体系的基础中，而且华盛顿目前正在进行的医疗改革辩论看起来根本不是关于削减成本。民主党人和共和党人正在争论谁将获得保险，以及公共选择，以及它是如何支付的。更不用说死亡小组和堕胎了。关于如何作为一个整体修复医疗保健体系以减缓威胁我们整个经济的失控成本，真的没有多少讨论。我们整个小时都在谈论的东西。
And so to end our hour, we invited somebody who's been following this very closely in Washington, DC, Susan Dentzer. She's been reporting on the politics and economics of health care since the 1980s for Newsweek , and then later for US News & World Report. She's seen HMOs come and go, she's seen Hillary Clinton's health care plan come and go, and now she's monitoring the latest attempt to remake the health care system as the editor of a policy journal called Health Affairs .
所以为了结束我们的小时，我们邀请了一位在华盛顿特区非常密切关注这一点的人，苏珊·登策(Susan Dentzer)。她自1980年代以来一直为《新闻周刊》(Newsweek)，后来为《美国新闻与世界报道》(US News & World Report)报道医疗保健的政治和经济。她见过HMO来来去去，她见过希拉里·克林顿(Hillary Clinton)的医疗改革计划来来去去，而现在她正在作为一本名为《健康事务》(Health Affairs)的政策期刊的编辑，监控重塑医疗保健体系的最新尝试。
And I'll be frank, when I sat down with her to talk about what is actually in the bills, she totally blew my mind. We'll get that part in a minute, but first, the actual detail of the bills when it comes to cutting costs. There is some stuff in these bills that addresses rising costs.
而且我要坦白，当我坐下来和她谈论法案中实际有什么时，她完全震惊了我。我们稍后会讲到那部分，但首先，当涉及削减成本时，法案的实际细节。在这些法案中有一些东西解决了上涨的成本。
If you are a glass half full kind of person, you look at it this way. There are some measures in the bills that would give the secretary of health and human services, among others, enormous authority to experiment with new ways to deliver health care.
如果你是一个乐观主义者，你会那样看它。法案中确实有一些措施赋予卫生与公众服务部长，除其他人之外，尝试新方法提供医疗保健的巨大权力。
This doesn't mean that little, experimental projects Dentzer says. The head of HHS will have czar like powers to change very basic things in how the system works by changing how Medicare pays doctors and hospitals.
这并不意味着那只是小的、实验性的项目，登策说。HHS(卫生与公众服务部)的首长将拥有类似沙皇的权力，通过改变医疗保险如何支付给医生和医院，来改变系统运作方式的基础事物。
And so for example, Medicare could stop paying fee for service. That system where doctors get money for every procedure that they do. They could bundle doctors and patients into groups to cut inefficiency and waste.
例如，医疗保险可以停止支付按服务付费。那个医生为他们做的每个程序得到钱的系统。他们可以将医生和病人捆绑成组以削减低效和浪费。
The bills also set up a Medicare commission, which could do the kind of restructuring and cutting that would be too hot politically for Congress to do itself.
法案还设立了一个医疗保险委员会，它可以做那种国会自己做政治上太热的重组和削减。
Now the weaknesses of these bills, Dentzer says, is that they don't force the head of HHS or anybody in the government to make any changes at all. There are no deadlines. And the amount that's going to get saved if everything goes perfectly, according to the Congressional Budget Office, is much smaller than health care costs are going to rise. But the idea is that Medicare is such a huge part of the health care system, it pays for a fourth of all the health care in the country. It's the biggest insurer in America. Changes made in Medicare would be adopted by others.
现在，登策说，这些法案的弱点是它们并不强迫HHS的首长或政府中的任何人做出任何改变。没有截止日期。而且如果一切进展顺利，根据国会预算办公室的说法，将要节省的金额比医疗保健成本上涨的金额要小得多。但想法是医疗保险是医疗保健体系如此巨大的一部分，它支付全国四分之一的医疗保健。它是美国最大的保险商。在医疗保险中所做的改变将被其他人所采用。
So the notion is to really create a platform for gradual change.
所以这个概念确实是为渐进式变革创造一个平台。
And is part of the impulse behind this basically to say, we are not going to agree in the Senate and the House on the exact ways to cut costs and exactly which things to do? And so let's just agree, somebody's going to do that. It's going to be the head of the Department of Health and Human Services and some of these other things that you're saying. But let's not discuss that here.
在这背后的冲动部分地基本上是说，我们不会在参议院和众议院就削减成本的准确方式和准确要做的那些事情达成一致？所以让我们只是同意，有人会做那个。那将是卫生与公众服务部首长和你说的一些其他东西。但让我们不要在这里讨论那个。
Yes, that's part of it. And the other realistic piece of this is if you tried to build all of this into the bill right now. If you said, we're going to make sweeping changes in the system. We're going to completely pay you in a totally different way. We're going to take you doctors who've been out in the hinterlands collecting your fee for service monies and basically restructure the system in such a way that you might have to live your life really differently. Just try putting that into a bill that gets everybody to accept it. You can't.
是的，那是其中的一部分。而这其中现实的部分是，如果你试图现在把所有这一切都放进法案里。如果你说，我们将对系统进行全面改变。我们将以一种完全不同的方式支付你们的钱。我们将把你们这些在偏远地区收集按服务付费钱的医生带走，并基本上重组系统，以至于你们可能不得不真正不同地生活。只要试着把那个放进一个让每个人都接受的法案里。你做不到。
Susan Dentzer told me that there are people in the administration who are deeply involved in the details of how to cut health care costs, and she talks to them. But she says they don't talk about this stuff much publicly for similar reasons. It's a political loser. It's a tough sell to say to people, not only will you get less health care, you'll be better off.
苏珊·登策告诉我，政府里有人深度参与了如何削减医疗保健成本的细节，而且她和他们谈话。但她说他们因为类似的原因公开谈论这些事情并不多。这是一个政治上的失败者。告诉人们不仅你将获得更少的医疗保健，你还会变得更好，这是一个艰难的推销。
OK, now I'm going to tell you the thing that Susan Dentzer says that totally shocked me. She told me that for the first time since she's been covering health care decades ago, all the major players in health care-- the hospitals, the insurance companies, the doctors-- she says they are all for the first time agreeing that something has to change. And she says this is the biggest political achievement made in health reform so far.
好的，现在我要告诉你苏珊·登策说的那个完全震惊我的事情。她告诉我，自从几十年前她开始报道医疗保健以来，医疗保健中的所有主要参与者——医院、保险公司、医生——她说他们所有人第一次同意必须有某种改变。她说这是医疗改革迄今为止取得的最大政治成就。
Almost all the stakeholders in health care have been at the table and are talking about all of this. They know that the system cannot persist the way it is. That we've got to do things differently. We have got to get more value out of the dollars spent on health care.
几乎所有的医疗保健利益相关者都在桌上，并且都在谈论所有这一切。他们知道系统不能以这种方式持续下去。我们必须以不同的方式做事。我们必须从医疗保健上花费的美元中获得更多价值。
How recent is that agreement? Is that because of Obama and his people like saying, OK, here's what we're going to do?
那个协议有多近？是因为奥巴马和他的人们说，好的，这是我们要做的？
Not really. We would probably be at this juncture no matter who had been elected president. Because of what was happening to the cost over the course of this decade.
不是真的。无论谁被选举为总统，我们都可能处于这个关口。因为在这个十年中成本所发生的事情。
Right, there's this growing consensus, like it's going up so fast.
对的，有这种日益增长的共识，就像它涨得如此快。
Well, health insurance premiums went up 130% from the year 2000 to now. Two years ago I was talking to an insurance executive from one of the leading insurance companies and I said, OK, so what's the situation like, and draw me the analogy with the threat alert system. You know, red alert, orange, green, whatever. He said, we're on red alert. We're on red alert. The system is falling apart.
嗯，医疗保险保费从2000年到现在上涨了130%。两年前我正在和一家领先保险公司的一位保险高管交谈，我说，好的，所以情况是什么样的，给我画一个关于威胁警报系统的比喻。你知道，红色警报，橙色，绿色，任何。他说，我们处于红色警报。我们处于红色警报。系统正在分崩离析。
The insurance companies?
保险公司？
Yes.
是的。
I'm just surprised to hear the insurance companies are on red alert because they are still making nice profits.
我只是惊讶听到保险公司处于红色警报，因为他们仍然在赚取不错的利润。
But they can see the handwriting on the wall. They see the system crumbling. They understand the pressures that will ensue if things get really out of hand. Just imagine if we had had 100 million people uninsured, what kind of pressures there would have been for, say, a single payer system. They know that. They think the only solution now for preserving any part of the system as a private system is to stop the bleeding now.
但他们可以看到墙上的笔迹。他们看到系统正在瓦解。如果事情真正失控，他们理解将随之而来的压力。只要想象如果我们有一亿人没有保险，那会有什么样的压力，比如，一个单一支付系统。他们知道这一点。他们认为现在为了保留系统作为私人系统的任何部分，唯一的解决方案是现在停止流血。
And so in addition to the health care reform happening in Washington, Susan Dentzer says there's a second reform that's happening right now all over the country. Hospitals and health care providers and state legislatures coming up with their own ways to restructure and contain costs. That's what gives her hope. That things are so hopeless for every player across the board that a consensus is actually taking hold that things can't continue as they have. And she sees people and organizations taking action.
所以除了在华盛顿发生的医疗改革之外，苏珊·登策说现在全国各地正在发生第二次改革。医院和医疗提供者以及州立法机构提出了他们自己的重组和遏制成本的方法。这就是给她希望的原因。事情对于跨平台的每个参与者来说都是如此绝望，以至于一个共识实际上正在占据上风，即事情不能像它们过去那样继续。而且她看到人们和组织正在采取行动。
Alix Spiegel is going to be doing more stories on this subject on NPR News . You can find those in the coming days at npr.org/health.
艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔将在NPR新闻上做更多关于这个主题的故事。你可以在接下来的几天里在npr.org/health找到它们。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who says, you know, you think people get upset when you mess with their health care. Try changing the broadcast time of Car Talk.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚(Torey Malatia)先生，他说，你知道，你认为当你们弄乱人们的医疗保健时人们会心烦意乱。尝试改变《汽车谈话》(Car Talk)的广播时间。
Lots of people wish that we would die. And lots of people wished that we would have a very slow death from a nasty cancer.
很多人希望我们死。很多人希望我们缓慢地死于讨厌的癌症。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with the second hour we're doing on health care. The Planet Money team takes on the insurance business right here on This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着我们正在做的关于医疗保健的第二个小时回来。Planet Money团队在这里，《美国生活》中接管保险业务。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。